das Jugendzentrum Arche in Berlin der
Krieg im Nahen Osten hat die Atmosphäre
auch hier verändert die Mehrheit der
Kinder und Jugendlichen stammt aus
muslimischen Familien viele haben eigene
Kriegserfahrungen wie der 14-Jährige
Ibrahim die Videos aus dem gaserstreifen
berühren ihn ganz besonders die Versuch
ihre Kinder zu rufen die gerade unter
Gebäuden sind sindunter und versade
zuufen das Handy tiktok Youtube sind die
wichtigsten Informationsquellen den
Konflikt kennen die meisten
ausschließlich aus der palästinensischen
Perspektive seitdem der krieggefahren
hat ist automatisch nur PAL Videos
gekommen ich kann ihn sagen dass jetzt
über
so 200 300 Videos über V gesehen habe wo
die Leute sterben seit fast 20 Jahren
arbeitet wolfgang Büscher für die Arche
wie emotional aufgeladen die Stimmung
ist hat er selbst zu spüren bekommen als
er kürzlich eine israelische Flagge am
jaett trug ein kleiner Junge so ungefähr
11 Jahre alt
sagte mir plötzlich du Wolfgang ich
hasse dich mein Opa kommt aus Palästina
und die Juden haben uns unser Land
weggenommen und wir hassen alle Juden
also seit dem
7 oktober hat sich das Ganze noch mal
verschärft das beobachtet auch Navid
Wali der influencer und gläubige Muslim
aus Frankfurt hat eine Mission er will
sich seine Religion zurückholen radikal
alle Prediger im Internet sagt er haben
Sie gekarpert wenn wir jetzt ins Netz
gehen würden und auf Youtube oder auf
Google und sie geben irgendwie eine
Frage zum Islam ein dann sind 90% der
der Antworten meistens aus irgendwelchen
randgruppierungen und diese
Instrumentalisierung meines Glaubens das
ist quasi der Antrieb um um dagegen zu
wirken seit Jahren beobachtet Navid Wali
die islamistische Szene so selbstbewusst
so radikal wie zuletzt habe er sie noch
nie
erlebt
Beispiel Essen Anfang November eine
Solidaritätskundgebung als
Machtdemonstration mit mehreren Kameras
gefilmt aufgearbeitet wie ein
Musikvideo dahinter steckt die
Gruppierung Generation Islam ihre Videos
tausendfach geteilt auf verschiedenen
plattformenarz ennnis Beobachter fühlen
sich an den is oder die Taliban erinnert
dazu die offene Forderung nach einem
Kalifat im Nahen Osten wenn man das
Ganze zu Ende denkt wird es dann kein
Israel so wie man das kennt geben das
schon sehr erschreckend und sehr wirksam
auch diese Bilder muss man sagen also
wenn ich mir vorstelle ich bin jetzt 16
Jahre alt ganz jung sie diese Bilder man
man trotz da quasi vor Selbstbewusstsein
das wür mich katchen als junger Mensch
wie sehr diese Bilder verfangen wissen
sie auch in der Arche damit wollen sie
die Jugendlichen nicht allein lassen und
reden drüber was wisst ihr über die
Situation im Nahen Osten Gespräche die
nicht leicht sind erlebt archegründer
Bernt siegelko dieser 13-jährige Junge
zeigt Verständnis für den Angriff der
Hamas und sieht Israel als
Aggressor israel hat immer mehr
angegriffen hat immer mehr erobert und
jetzt wollen die halt wieder
zurück sie wollen jetzt ihr Land wieder
zurückholen indem sie Kinder umbringen
und Frau aber Israel hat es doch da wo
die mehr Leute mehr Land angenommen
haben auch gemacht die haben einfach
getötet man hat ja gemerkt was sie alles
wissen vielleicht auch sehr einseitig
gar keine Frage sie werden ständig damit
konfrontiert beeinflusst ganz bestimmt
auch von Elternhäusern von Familien aber
eben auch von Hasspredigern da muss man
einfach ganz offen drüber sein das
wissen wir
auch mit dem Hass auf Israel Stimmung
machen im Netz und auf der
straßem von der Gruppierung Generation
Islam macht vor wie es
geht an Deutschland an Israels Seite
steht
dieg deutschen stat ist d sie das was
Israel gerade tut den Genozid im
konzentrationager von dass sie das
bedingungsl
unterstützen Gaza ein
Konzentrationslager wir fragen nach bei
Generation Islam ein Interview geben sie
uns nicht die Antwort kommt über
YouTube
ist zunächst einmal nicht im Kontext des
Dritten Reiches entstanden sondern er
ist weitaus älter die Begriffsgeschichte
geht bis auf den kubanischen
Unabhängigkeitskrieg gegen Spanien
zurück für Navid Wali ein
Ablenkungsmanöver mit dem Kontext
unserer Geschichte in Deutschland und
vor allem mit dem was wirklich
Konzentrationslager sind ist es eine
absolute verhamlosung Relativierung
dieser
Geschichte für die Aktivitäten
vonation interessiert sich auch der
Verfassungsschutz im aktuellen Bericht
werden neben Generation Islam auch die
Gruppierungen Realität Islam und Muslim
interaktiv genannt sie seinen
propagandistisch außerordentlich aktiv
NRW Innenminister R drängt auf
Konsequenzen ich for dass die
Organisation die wir da benennen
vielleicht gibt's noch mehr geprüft
werden und am besten verboten werden ich
fordere von uns selber dass wir bei den
Plakaten und Texten noch sorgfältiger
schauen wie sehr Hass und Hetze
zugenommen haben das merken Sie auch bei
der Frankfurter
Generalstaatsanwaltschaft eine
Sondereinheit kämpft gegen
Internetkriminalität und untersucht
nicht nur hassposts sondern auch
Kommentare wenn ich z.B jemand postet
das ist geil geil ist das klare
Befürwortung der hamassangriffe da
werden ein paar Strafrecht relevante
auch dabei sein es geht um die Belegung
von
Straftaten bei manchen fehlt tatsächlich
so diese dieses Empfinden dafür dass man
auch im Rahmen der Meinungsfreiheit
Grenzen zu ziehen hat wenn es also darum
geht dass der Angriff der herrass vom 7
Oktober befürwortet wird dass er auf gut
deutsch gefeiert wird oder wenn zum zum
Hass auf aufgerufen aufgestachelt wird
dann ist es natürlich ganz Klar strafbar
und das müssen wir ganz konsequent
verfolgen so wie diesen Post der die
Angriffe der Hamas auf Israel bejubelt
mehr als 700 solcher Fälle haben sie
seit dem 7 Oktober arbeitet fast die
Hälfte davon strafrechtlich
relevant deswegen sind wir auch dabei
und so engagiert dieses Thema auch
prioritär zu behandeln weil natürlich
immer die Gefahr besteht dass sich so
eine Stimmung aus dem Netz auf die
Straße verlagert und dann irgendwann gar
nicht mehr kontrollierbar ist es
[Applaus]
re wie gezielt versucht wird Straße und
Netz zu instrumentalisieren zeigt sich
auch in Frankfurt Ende Oktober das nicht
ausre hat das i istbde nun auch
sämtliche
Kommunikationsinfrastruktur
zerbt auch hier Israel als Feindbild und
die Forderung nach einem
Kalifat su Reimund Hoffmann ist einer
der Köpfe der Organisation realitä Islam
vor einer aktuellen Flyer Kampagne
dieser Gruppierung warnt der häische
Verfassungsschutz sie sei antisemitisch
auch weil sie den Staat Israel in
Anführungszeichen setzt und ihm so das
Existenzrecht
abspreche gerne hätten wir dazu mit
Hoffmann gesprochen auf eine Anfrage von
Frontal aber reagieren weder er noch
Realität
Islam nabid Wali beobachtet die
Gruppierung schon lange und hält sie für
gefährlich die Bilder der Frankfurter
Demo hat er auf seinem eigenen Account
geteilt so will er vor ihrer Propaganda
warnen ich nehme einen großen Riss der G
war und das spielt natürlich
extremistischen Gruppierungen in die
Hände weil wir ganz viele junge Menschen
haben die nicht wissen wo sie hingehen
sollen mit ihren Emotionen das ist eine
große Herausforderung und die
extremistischen Ränder machen sich das
natürlich zu eigenen den Islam nicht den
Extremisten überlassen weder im Netz
noch auf der Straße dafür kämpft Navid
Wali